[Music]
what are these four moners seen in the
legacy of Monsters the trailer and the
one from gxk the hunted Comics I mean
the teased images aside from Godzilla
the real top G nerds let's get to
discussing the four others and listen
closely about the black flying
creature firstly the spider- looking
monster seen in a glimpse fighting
another crap likee monster in Legacy of
the Monsters trailer OB obvously this is
a mother long legs these are towering
super species at approximately 20 ft in
height their remarkable adaptation
includes exceptionally long legs that
mimic bamboo stalks providing a Dem with
unparallel camouflage within the Lush
surroundings of the Island's Forest what
you might not know is that they have a
head that resembles a skull but with
eight eyes and smaller claws to feed
with surprisingly the one we saw in
Skull Island is just an average Joe
there is also a bigger more massive
specimen called The Queen Mother long
legs and this creature was seen in the
birth of Kong comics and it can venture
to other habitats other than the bamboo
forest it might actually be the one
fighting the crap likee creature in the
trailer how awesome would that be two
minor monsters fighting for territory in
a god forsaken place all righty then now
that we know what these sexy long legs
are what about the Monstrous crap likee
creature another one in our pants we
haven't seen them before in the monster
verse that's for sure so this might be a
new one for the Monarch series first of
all I thought that it might have been
one of those creatures seen in the Skull
Island animated series if you have seen
it then you know what I'm talking about
these are called the trapo crabs and
they take the form of large Crustaceans
spotting prominent Red Claws and their
bodies exhibit a rounded and grayish
appearance complemented by several
pointed and segmented legs on each side
they also appear to be armored by a
chiten exoskeleton like all other crap
species they are also found in beaches
near the sea but they rarely Venture
away from the Sands anyway this crap
likee creature seen in the trailer
doesn't seem to have red pencils but it
does look to be near the ocean so what
I'm theorizing here is that this might
be a king trapo crab and he will battle
the Queen Mother long legs King versus
queen that is some Game of Thrones
monster right here now guys what
about the flying monster is it searching
for something well the trailer
introduces a mysterious flying creature
the distinct from known Titans like duto
Rodan chots or Mothra it possesses a
dragon-like body with evolved for limbs
as Wings also smaller legs with sharp
claws and batlik wings with segmented
membranes the serpentine tail ends in a
fork design though its facial features
remain hidden a brief Glimpse reveal a
resemblance to the Flying banshees of
Avatar but much more terrifying flying
just above the tree canopy and breaking
out from the ship it appears to be in
the size range of vagar from House of
the Dragon estimating at around 30 to 40
ft tall or 9 to 12 M with a wingspan of
over 200 ft wide and an equal length of
200 ft from head to tail we also saw the
coordinates which are
31.4659 a horn creature in myths and
legends a goat faac demon worshiped by
Cults and Templars well this creature
also has horns and has a long face but
it has wings but then again baffet the
demon also had wings interestingly
enough the coordinates showcased in the
trailer for a split second is something
that we can actually hold up in court uh
numbers pointing up to a location where
titanus baffet was hibernating in kotm
but if you think about it again the
trailer clip could be in Skull Island
and before kotm so how does this tie up
or link up to each other well it might
be that this monster was actually like a
cot's minion but for baffet trying to
wake up the larger Titan the real baffet
in Morocco and it could be the
overarching theme to the series this is
occurring to me in real time right now
and it makes sense as the character Lee
Shaw has information that could prove
fatal to the world and it could be the
discovery of this Titan baffet or trying
to prevent it from Awakening by putting
down the the black dragon-like creature
wo this could be an interesting
storyline and it will link up what
happens before kotm and yeah they did
say that they were going to bring back
old Titans and new ones well this one
will fit both shoes now let's take a
look at the Titan that was seen fighting
Kong in released images of gxk the
hunted we can clearly state that this is
a mammal Titan smaller than the adult
Kong about 1/3 of its height at around
100 ft tall and around 200 to 250 ft
long it seems to look like a cat or a
panther but you know with a more
monstrous face and longer claws now what
Titan is it is it a new one or one of
the named but unseen ones from kotm well
as far as I can say to my knowledge
there is one particular Titan that might
be catlike and that is segment while not
physically present in the movie Godzilla
king of the monsters features segment in
an ancient carving during the opening
sequence as well as being seen in the
names you know the Titan locations the
depiction of segment is like that of a
lius with a Slender Man extending from
her head down the back and notably she
is portrayed with Aven like heims and
gripping claws well director Michael dhy
has emphasized that segment exhibits
feline characteristics similar to a
sphinx or a lioness could this be her
well I'm 50% sure which means either I
could be wrong or right but we'll find
out soon enough so that's the end of the
video and if you like this one then
watch this other one as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
monsters and creatures you know Monster
content then check out our Channel as
well we might just have things that you
haven't seen before or thought about
like subscribe and we'll see you on the
next one take care fam